kids are back in school this week and
that's where we're going to begin with
the tough choices facing parents these
days covet cases among america's
children are surging to all-time highs
more than 252 thousand kids tested
positive for covet 19 in the last week
alone think about that for a second
because that's the highest total ever in
a seven day stretch according to the
american academy of pediatrics the
academy says that children accounted for
more than 26 percent of all coveted
cases in the u.s in that week alone now
this is sure to be very alarming news
for parents as millions of kids head
back to the classroom and fights fights
between the parents are breaking out in
states like florida and texas over
safety measures maria villarreal is in
san antonio where covett outbreaks are
already affecting the school year there
maria good morning to you
hey good morning gail here in texas less
than 60 percent of the eligible
population is actually vaccinated that
is with pediatric cases surging and the
delta variant spreading very quickly
here's what we know more than 50 000
students tested positive inside texas
schools in the last three weeks that is
leaving parents very concerned by what
they say is a lack of transparency from
school district officials
i just want peace of mind when it comes
to
my child and their safety and their
education for lindsay harrison sending
her three kids back to school has been a
source of anxiety and stress
her oldest child is immunocompromised in
a district where masks are not mandatory
and in the first eight days of school
250 notices of positive infections like
this one have been sent to families but
harrison says they're missing key
information about who is sick like at
our third grader's school kinder ranch
elementary why can't we know
every time a kinder ranch
affiliated person is testing positive
for covid whether it's a sub whether
it's a teacher whether it's
administration or if it's a student
according to the texas tribune at least
45 school districts across the state
have suspended in-person learning
following spikes in infections the lone
star state recording a record in
pediatric hospitalizations over the
weekend dr norm christopher is the chief
medical officer of the children's
hospital of san antonio there is no
doubt that the frequency at which
children are being infected
is dramatically increased and their
symptoms are greater as well the number
of children requiring hospitalization is
higher the number of kids requiring
intensive care monitoring and treatment
is higher now than it was during the
first or the second surge and even with
cases surging texas is not allowing
school districts to offer virtual
learning for public school students
which has parents like harrison feeling
powerless especially when the scope of
some outbreaks is unclear if we can't be
transparent in that information then
like what sort of normal are we getting
back to
we do reach out to kamau isd they did
not want to talk to us on camera but
sent us a statement saying in part that
when somebody tests positive student or
staff member they do send home a letter
to parents on that same day and if
parents believe that their child was in
close contact with that person they can
ask for an excused absence they also
clarify that they do give out
information about the grade level of the
sick person but by law they can't give
out any identifying information and that
is what is confusing and concerning to
parents tony
boy maria 50 000 cases in that state
alone that's a lot of rolls of the dice
thank you very much